sri lanka's acting president has
declared a state of emergency across the
entire country he said the measure was
necessary to maintain security and
essential supplies
raniel wickramasinga took over the sri
lankan leadership on friday after the
previous president was ousted by mass
protests
shortages of food fuel and medicine have
provoked widespread anger
lawmakers are due to elect a new
president on wednesday
and let's bring in dw south asia bureau
chief amrita chima who is joining me
from the sri lankan capital colombo
amrita what powers does this emergency
declaration give the sri lankan
authorities
instead of this extraordinary gazette
which was passed and issued by the
interim acting president gives enhanced
powers to all the security forces and
this means the police as well as the
army the police have also been here in
high presence but a lot of soldiers have
also been deployed if you look behind me
lurking in the shadows there are a lot
of army soldiers now the aim is really
to avoid what happened last week if you
remember outside the prime minister's
office there were ugly scenes scuffles
broke out tear gas was fired and at that
time
became a singer the acting president
said he's going to stop fascist elements
taking over these princes and by that he
met fringe elements radical fringe
elements who are trying to keep things
hijack what is essentially a peaceful
project
and america we understand security is
tight as parliament chooses a new
president
how high meantime is the risk of fresh
protest
that will really depend on the outcome
of the election in parliament we have
four contenders for the post of
president the idea was to have a unity
government but given the situation at
the moment the opposition is hopelessly
divided so the
party with the maximum number of seats
in parliament right now is voted by
rajapaksa's own party and that makes the
acting president daniel victim a singer
a clear favorite to win the poster
president now many of the protesters are
not happy with that thought but there
are others who believe he's the only one
who has the wherewithal to pull the
country back from this brink of economic
chaos because he knows how to deal with
the imf and an imf bailout will be
needed to secure the future of this
country
okay so given that amarita how are the
events of recent days playing into the
economic crisis would you say
pretty significantly as we've been
reporting all these days people are
finding the economic pinch
very very uh strong there's not enough
fuel here there's not enough food prices
are going out going up inflation is said
to be 50 and economists say it's going
to go up to 70 percent economy is
contracting by six percent so the
situation is very dire for the people
and the longer it takes for a government
to come in power which is able to
actually put in economic policies
in place the more impatient people are
getting they are now report that a new
fuel shipment is arriving in the country
either today or tomorrow people need
every drop of fuel that they can get
because it's impacting every aspect of
their lives
i'm rita chima thank you so much amarita
is dw's south asia bureau chief joining
us with the view from the sri lankan
capital colombo